extranjero
[Música]
estamos en la transmisión en vivo de inferencia activa
número 50.1 el 20 de octubre de 2022.
estamos discutiendo la intercepción del papel
como modelado de alostasis como control
bienvenido al instituto de inferencia activa
somos un instituto participativo en línea
que se está comunicando  aprendiendo
y practicando inferencia activa aplicada
esto está grabado en una transmisión en vivo archivada
, así que envíe sus comentarios para que
podamos mejorar nuestro trabajo
todos los antecedentes y perspectivas son
bienvenidos y seguiremos la
etiqueta de video para transmisiones en vivo
diríjase a
activeinference.org para obtener más información
cómo involucrarse con diferentes
grupos de aprendizaje y proyectos como las
transmisiones en vivo y, de lo contrario
, estamos aquí en la transmisión en vivo número 50.1
con nuestra segunda discusión sobre la interceptación del papel
como modelado de alostasis como
control
anteriormente teníamos el número 50.0 donde Dean
y yo proporcionamos algunos antecedentes  y
contexto y ahora estamos muy
agradecidos de que algunos
autores se unan para el punto uno  y dos
para desempaquetar y explorar algunas ideas
y hoy será genial escuchar a
varios autores, ver una pequeña
presentación y sumergirse en el medio de las
cosas, el meollo de las cosas, como lo hacemos en
el punto uno
, así que comenzaremos con  presentaciones,
luego tendremos una presentación y
luego una discusión, así que comenzaremos con
presentaciones con los no autores primero
y pueden sentirse libres de presentar, saludar
y cualquier cosa que estén emocionados de
explorar hoy, así que soy Daniel, soy un
investigador en California
y estoy ansioso por comprender
algunos de los formalismos en el modelo y
cómo se conectan con la inferencia activa y
la mecánica bayesiana y le pasaré a Dave
hola, soy Dave, soy
un
curador de discursos, un estudiante de  Jacques lo
punks y Mark soles Vivo en la
ciudad académica de una milla de altura de Baguio 200
kilómetros al norte de Manila Dean
gracias Dave Soy Dean Estoy en Calgary
um
lo que es interesante para mí es que
en un nivel metafórico esto comenzó
conmigo en un  en un campo abierto y conseguí  en
un bosque y ese bosque se volvió más denso y
abollado y cuando llegamos a la sección
cuatro de este documento, comencé a
leerlo una y otra vez, lo cual es una
señal fantástica porque si tengo que leer algo
muchas veces para entender realmente
en torno a eso,
eso es bueno porque no cuestiono las
cosas a menos que no las entienda, eso
no significa que no se haya
explicado correctamente, solo significa que llamaste
mi atención, así
que no estoy seguro de qué autor.  para pasárselo
a First, tal vez Eli, te gustaría
saludar a todos,
um, soy Eli, soy el primer autor de este
artículo,
así que,
un poco antes de que comenzara la transmisión en vivo,
Jordan mencionó que este trabajo
surge de lo que  Estábamos
estudiando juntos en nuestro laboratorio en un
grupo de trabajo de energía, grupo de
lectura de energía cerebral antes de que
la pandemia realmente nos golpeara
, así que cuando estaba
confinado
, sabes, efectivamente comencé a leer
y releer, sabes todo por lo que
habíamos pasado y tratando de
salir adelante.  Con algo  manera
de pensar en la alostasis porque
en nuestro grupo y en nuestras
Publicaciones anteriores como grupo El
laboratorio de ciencias afectivas del acto interdisciplinario hemos hecho mucha referencia a la alostasis
y cada vez le preguntaría cómo
podemos dar una caracterización matemática o
computacional
de la alostasis.  básicamente me dirían
bueno
, sabes que pensamos que Peter Sterling tenía
uno
y luego iría a ver a Peter
Sterling y
, por cierto, él es el creador del concepto de
alostasis, por lo que hay
numerosos trabajos suyos sobre el tema,
probablemente la forma más larga
, digamos
no  -el tratamiento experto probablemente sería
su libro, qué es la salud,
oye,
y cuando mirara
el trabajo de Sterling, detectaría una
contradicción o una contradicción en los
términos,
uno de un
lado, está trazando específicamente la variación
en los parámetros fisiológicos y la
regulación a lo
largo del tiempo donde  el tiempo puede ser el curso
de toda una vida en el curso del
desarrollo o incluso solo el curso de un
solo día
y aún así  por otro lado, si le preguntas
bien cómo se hace esto,
efectivamente
diría que esto se hace mediante el aprendizaje por refuerzo a
través de los sistemas dopaminérgicos en
el cerebro
ahora los sistemas dopaminérgicos en el
cerebro no rastrean una señal cambiante con el
tiempo, solo maximizan la recompensa
y, en realidad, desde mi punto de vista, al menos como
computacionalista, eran más
homeostáticos que alostáticos
y de esa contradicción y lo que
siguió realmente surgió
todo este documento
extraño,
pero para volver a enfatizar, diría y
antes de saltar al
material de las diapositivas.  dentro del documento
, creo que realmente vale la pena enfatizar
solo en base a ver la transmisión en vivo 50.0
que
nuestro grupo son más, digamos, biólogos
y fisiólogos en orientación que
físicos,
por lo que bayesiano El documento sobre
mecánica bayesiana salió mientras escribíamos
esto
y yo no  creo que realmente logramos
integrar los dos conjuntos de material
juntos
o juntos pero
eso no quiere decir que no puedan o
no deban ser  integrado es decir
que en realidad no tenemos,
por así decirlo, no siempre tenemos la
experiencia en física y sistemas dinámicos
de alguien como Thomas Parr o Maxwell
Ramstead, y mucho menos Karl Kristen, por
otro lado
, tenemos nociones muy concretas de lo que es
biología y  La fisiología a la que debemos
adaptarnos es realmente la mayor parte de este documento, ya
sabes, la razón por la que no es solo una
sección corta con algunas matemáticas
es porque tenemos que adaptarnos a la
fisiología y la anatomía que conocemos,
gracias Jordan, siéntete libre de introducir y
luego, Eli te invitará a hacer una
presentación, así que soy un
posdoctorado en el laboratorio aquí, así que creo que tal
vez solo daré un contexto de dónde
estamos trabajando ambos y cómo hemos llegado
aquí, así que
para mí.  Tuve un camino un poco extraño para
llegar a este punto en el que hice mi doctorado
en psicología social y
psicología moral,
um, entonces, uh, una especie de trans
se interesó mucho en
las perspectivas del procesamiento predictivo y la
inferencia activa y luego realmente quería  cavar
yo  n a eso y encuentre a alguien que esté trabajando
en eso aquí en Boston eh, así que estoy
trabajando con Lisa Feldman Barrett y
Karen rápidamente, quienes codirigen el
laboratorio interdisciplinario de ciencias afectivas
aquí
um y les gusta que digan que la
perspectiva que tenemos es realmente más
de una base biológica o más
de una que se basa en um en fisiología
y neurociencia Entonces Lisa y Carol bromean diciendo
que Lisa maneja todo
desde el cuello hacia arriba y Karen maneja
todo desde el cuello hacia abajo así que
juntos forman una persona completa
um
y qué  lo que realmente tuve suerte de hacer
fue tropezar con,
um,
una colaboración existente que estuvo
ocurriendo durante aproximadamente una década aquí,
um, que llamamos el
grupo de neurociencia de ingeniería psicológica o el
grupo de pluma
donde ha habido una
colaboración continua con profesores de
ingeniería eléctrica.  departamento
probablemente lo más importante es que Dana Brooks
realmente ha ayudado mucho a administrarlo, que
Dennis Abdogmas y Jennifer D
también han sido l  Estoy realmente muy involucrado en
esto,
um
, así que lo que harían es reunirse
todas las semanas y sacar
adelante los documentos de interés activo.
Procesar documentos. Teoría de la información.
entender la ingeniería y tratamos de
ponerlos al día en una especie de
comprensión biológica de la neurociencia
también, así
que
lo que realmente nos ha
interesado es
pensar en algunas de las abstracciones
que surgieron en el acto de la literatura de inferencia.
y pensando en cómo poner a
tierra esos procesos
biológicos y cómo hacer que esto sea realmente manejable
a un nivel biológico empírico, por lo que
el interés que he tenido en la
energía cerebral ha sido
una forma de aplicar parte de esa
tracción a
mi interés original.  que es una especie de
normas morales y sociales, así que he trabajado un
poco
pensando en cómo podemos pensar en la
información o los costos energéticos del procesamiento de la
información como una forma  de
cómo los individuos ejercen control sobre un
entorno social al ajustarse a las
expectativas dentro de él
y luego, al mismo tiempo, me ha
interesado ir al otro extremo
y pensar en algunos de los
detalles del metabolismo cerebral y el metabolismo de la
glucosa cerebral que son  asociado
con la señal Bold fmri para que realmente podamos
profundizar en el
metabolismo que subyace a la imagen neuronal.
Su imagen en la literatura,
um, pero en el proceso de
realizar básicamente esto o formar este
grupo de lectura energética donde hemos
estado investigando todo  esos temas para
tratar de entender la biología del cerebro
Eli y yo realmente terminamos trabajando
juntos en este documento para tratar de aplicar
algo de ese
trabajo energético y biológico
nuevamente con mucha ayuda de Karen
y Lisa, quienes realmente conocen los detalles
de  la neurociencia y la
fisiología real, creo que Karen, especialmente que
Eli probablemente diría, ha sido
muy, muy, muy crítica para la
ONU  Entendiendo estos
sistemas fisiológicos,
um,
pero básicamente sí, cómo podemos
tener algunos de los parámetros y
suposiciones de estos
modelos de
inferencia activos basados ​​en términos biológicos reales de los que
podemos comenzar a buscar en la literatura empírica, la
literatura biológica biológica
y obtener algo más
de inspiración.  que en lugar de
vivir viviendo completamente en un
nivel abstracto,
genial y con eso se lo entregaré a
Eli,
excelente, está bien,
no lo he compartido, siéntete libre de hacerlo,
gracias por ese contexto
y solo como nota,
um, lo hizo,
um, este artículo.  trae algunos
temas que no hemos discutido en ninguno
de los 50 documentos anteriores,
muchos de los cuales también fueron motivadores de
lo que
te propusiste explorar, así que solo recortaré el
tamaño y así sucesivamente y Eli, por favor, hazlo
todo.  Bien,
um,
así que antes de entrar realmente en el material
del artículo, creo que podría ser
útil continuar con lo que dijo Jordan
para motivar adicionalmente
nuestro giro hacia la biología.  y Fisiología
aquí,
que es que la mayor parte del tiempo
modelado de inferencia inactivo
tenga en cuenta que digo modelado o una
física interna activa, por así
decirlo, necesita un término en su energía libre esperada
o en su densidad conjunta
que lo siento, la densidad conjunta generativa
no el reconocimiento  uno al
que llamarías a menudo. Lo he oído
llamar a las preferencias previas
esencialmente una densidad de probabilidad sobre
los resultados sensoriales que describe lo
que es difícil evitar el
lenguaje antropomórfico aquí, pero bueno, lo que
quieres observar
ahora en sistemas biológicos reales que
conoces como nosotros.  tipo de puede escuchar de Peter
Sterling
o de muchos otros autores que no se pueden
arreglar,
es decir, usted sabe que las preferencias previas
no se pueden arreglar, prefiero
diferentes observaciones cuando estoy a punto de
irme a dormir versus cuando me estoy despertando
y  la suposición que generalmente se
convierte en
principios como, digamos, el principio de energía libre
es que en
realidad déjenme moderar eso un poco en
base a la conversación  s con algunos
principios de energía libre, amigos,
si tienen una formulación del principio de energía libre basada en el estado y no basada en rutas,
entonces normalmente
asumirán algo llamado ergoticidad
y notarán que tenemos un apéndice
sobre ergoticidad que vi que
discutieron  la semana pasada en el episodio de punto cero,
gracias por darse cuenta de
eso y gracias a todos los
miembros de la audiencia y los oyentes que se dieron
cuenta de que
la suposición de ergodicidad esencialmente
le permite cambiar la incertidumbre sobre el
tiempo o a lo largo del tiempo por la incertidumbre en el
momento.
así que puedes decir que hay una
densidad de preferencia previa gaussiana
, tiene tanta precisión o tanta
variación dependiendo de
qué manera prefieres poner tu
signo de división
y
luego es lo mismo para siempre
ahora si estás haciendo un camino.  formulación basada
entonces
se pierde el vínculo entre el
principio de energía libre y
las nociones fisiológicas convencionales de la
homeostasis
porque ahora, después de todo, el punto de referencia no puede
ser  cualquier cosa o todo
lo que necesita saber algo sobre
fisiología Anatomía para vincularlo
y esa es realmente la motivación de la
que venimos en este documento es qué
sucede si tiene que adquirir o aprender preferencias previas a lo
largo del desarrollo
qué tan poco puede hornear
y así  comenzamos revisando en
el documento y en estas diapositivas el tipo
de perspectivas que estudiamos desde estudiar
el sistema nervioso estudiar el cerebro
uno de ellos es el procesamiento predictivo
creo que probablemente será el
importante para esta audiencia y en
predictivo  procesamiento, hablamos de
los sistemas de percepción del cerebro, en
realidad los sistemas sensoriales
realizan una inferencia bayesiana aproximada,
por lo que tendrá señales de predicción de arriba hacia abajo,
señales de error de predicción de abajo hacia arriba
y existe esta noción de inferencia activa
que dice que esencialmente tratamos el
motor  salidas
como parámetros para el modelo de reconocimiento
en una de sus primeras
formulaciones antes de que existiera
energía libre esperada
Pero, en última instancia, todavía dice que en cualquier
formulación nueva o reciente tenemos alguna
noción de error de predicción
entre densidades y esta es una
cantidad teórica de información,
por lo que realmente estamos hablando de una
Divergencia o una entropía o una entropía cruzada
que queremos minimizar  eso y no
solo vamos a minimizar eso al cambiar
las predicciones de arriba hacia abajo que fluyen a
través de la corteza sensorial,
también vamos a cambiar estos
parámetros adicionales que corresponden a
las predicciones motoras, los comandos motores, las referencias motoras,
según la terminología
que utilice.  quiero usar para referirme a ellos,
así que en nuestro laboratorio, donde somos una especie de
biólogos de la emoción
, a menudo estudiamos la intercepción
y eso es realmente una
definición bastante vaga en la diapositiva aquí
porque hay mucho debate entre los
neuroanatomistas sobre el lugar de la
intercepción.  termina y comienza la recepción x-star,
qué modalidades exactas deben
clasificarse de qué manera u otra,
pero en realidad la intercepción es st  Entiendo un
conjunto o categoría de modalidades sensoriales
y cuando digo modalidades sensoriales estoy
mencionando eso específicamente porque la
literatura sobre la inferencia activa interceptiva
tiende a tomar lo que podríamos llamar
la forma más temprana de inferencia activa
, toma el camino de la forma más temprana
de inferencia activa.  inferencia activa decir tengo una
densidad generativa tengo una densidad de reconocimiento la
acción se convierte efectivamente en un parámetro
para ajustar la densidad de reconocimiento a la
densidad generativa
y no hay realmente una noción de
un modelo generativo interno que
esté separado que separe la creencia y el
deseo en  En mucha literatura sobre
inferencia activa interceptiva
, encontrará referencias a tener
antecedentes muy precisos
o incluso conocerá antecedentes innatos sobre
parámetros interceptivos
y verá esta noción de
que usa la inferencia activa en el
dominio interceptivo más de lo que lo usa
en  el dominio somático
porque estás tratando de ajustar tu
fisiología interna a una noción de
punto de ajuste a priori  ts que están determinados
por la evolución
, ¿crees que podrías dar un ejemplo
de eso, Eli y qué tipo de puntos fijos la
gente podría
pensar bien,
veamos, he visto
niveles de dióxido de carbono en la sangre,
niveles de glucosa mencionados,
um, la temperatura corporal central es realmente la
uno al que tiendo a volver porque
realmente permanece constante la mayor parte del
tiempo, puede variar, pero en realidad ese es un
tipo de situación inextremis,
así que si piensas en la temperatura corporal central,
hay un circuito y creo que sabes
Jordan corrígeme si yo  Me equivoco, pero este
es el NTS nuevamente, ¿no son
los factores
centrales?
probabilidad fija,
no puede ser reparametrizado
por alguna predicción que fluya desde más
arriba
o, más bien, la mayoría de las veces no está
reparametrizado, por
lo que fluye hacia abajo como una predicción y
el  n cada sensor de temperatura en el
cuerpo
puede comparar la temperatura real con la
temperatura deseada
calcular un
error de predicción ponderado de precisión entre ellos
enviar esos errores nuevamente
y luego el cerebro puede decir ajá, necesito
encontrar una manera de minimizar estos errores
y hacerlo mantendrá efectivamente
usted en un entorno donde puede
mantener su temperatura corporal central a su
alrededor, creo que es 98.6 Fahrenheit es
el estereotipo
que varía para los individuos
ahora la razón por la que mi próxima diapositiva fue sobre la
alostasis
es porque
si bien hay parámetros burbujeantes como
la temperatura central
que generalmente se comportan de acuerdo  a un punto fijo
realmente fisiológicamente la mayoría de los parámetros
no tienen un punto fijo
ellos mueven los niveles regulados se mueven todo
el tiempo
así que eso incluye la frecuencia cardíaca
presión arterial azúcar en la
sangre niveles de oxígeno en la sangre
varios niveles de hormonas en los sistemas endocrinos los
niveles de inflamación
cambian con el tiempo
y mencioné  inflamación porque
sabes desde la perspectiva del cuerpo
allí  Si sabe que la inflamación no es
algo con un punto fijo de cero, la
inflamación a veces es apropiada
y, de hecho, si quiere pensar que
sabe cuál es la situación en la que la
adaptación de todos estos parámetros básicos
es fisiológicamente adaptativa,
entonces
creo que
el ejercicio intenso y la enfermedad
son  probablemente los dos ejemplos más grandes,
por lo que para el ejercicio intenso podríamos hablar
de niveles de excitación
y eso se refiere al equilibrio de
la actividad cooperativa en las ramas del
sistema nervioso autónomo,
pero esencialmente si vas a salir
a correr,
digamos de un depredador o  después de un poco de comida
en tu chica, ya sabes, Evo,
psicología, entorno ancestral
, vas a necesitar disminuir la
actividad en algunos sistemas de órganos, aumentar
la actividad en otros sistemas de órganos
y ajustar los
parámetros fisiológicos para regularlos a los nuevos
niveles,
así que esto es un bonito  hecho bien observado
de la fisiología
, conoces informalmente a
Peter Sterling, diría que
inventé la alostasis como una observación
eso se
hace, luego lo
editorializa un poco al respecto y
dice que debería reemplazar la
homeostasis como un modo de regulación,
por lo que en lugar de tener puntos fijos,
debería compararse con algo así como una
trayectoria establecida
y, en el caso ideal, cuando esté
teorizando, debería  suponga que
no hay
un punto de ajuste global de ningún parámetro
y, por supuesto, como mencionamos antes en los
extremistas, esto es cierto si se enferma,
su cuerpo realmente anula ese
circuito en el tronco cerebral
para elevar la temperatura central, por
eso tendrá escalofríos.  estás a la misma
temperatura
pero el nivel regulado se ha desplazado
hacia arriba
también hay un
punto interesante que hacer si retrocedes por un segundo
te gusta solo eso um en la forma en que
el tipo de lenguaje de la ciencia evoluciona
aquí también y  vale la pena señalarlo
porque algunas personas podrían estar escuchando
y podrían estar pensando que
usted sabe bien que la homeostasis no tiene
que incluir puntos fijos o puede
tener una especie de océano de oro más alto
estasis de uponio puedes tener, um, sabes, una especie de
múltiples niveles de control involucrados en
eso y algunas personas han hecho la misma
crítica de la alostasis como un océano, así que
hay un artículo de Carpenter
por Carpenter que hace exactamente esto
bien,
pero el problema es  es que incluso si
eso es técnicamente cierto y las
personas que realmente saben lo que están
haciendo y están usando un concepto de
homeostasis de esa manera ya podrían
entender que no necesariamente
necesita puntos fijos,
pero la realidad es que el camino
la homeostasis tiende a usarse de la manera en
que tiende a entenderse
si tiene algo de esta asociación
con puntos fijos o con un
modelo de termostato simple en lugar de algo
más amplio que incluye múltiples niveles de
control y, por lo tanto,
algunas personas que podrían estar  algunas personas
pueden ser cascarrabias y quieren decir
que la homeostasis ya incluye todas
estas nociones, por lo que deberíamos reclamar
el término homeostasis para eso
, creo que estamos  más de la perspectiva de
que estamos dispuestos a renunciar a eso
y podría ser hora de comenzar a usar
un término diferente para recordarle a la gente
esas otras asociaciones, así
que estamos sembrando un poco de terreno
cuando estamos usando  el término alostasis
para simplemente no tener que pelear con la gente
sobre lo que realmente significa homeostasis,
sí, entonces Jordan tiene toda la razón
allí, pero en realidad incluso
recomendaría que conozca a todos los que
escuchan si puede buscar el papel
homeostasis una petición para un
enfoque unificado por parte de rhs  Carpenter está en nuestras
citas y debería poder escribir
el nombre en Google Scholar, vaya a verlo
porque realmente explicará de dónde
proviene nuestro artículo
como un breve resumen de lo que es relevante.
Lo que dice Carpenter en su artículo es
que en  los buenos viejos tiempos enseñaban
teoría de control e ingeniería de control
a los fisiólogos y eso incluía
a fisiólogos de investigación y también
clínicos
y en el pasado él realmente quiere decir
volver a como  desde la década de 1940 hasta la década de 1960
antes de que se hiciera cargo otro nuevo enfoque
y ella dice: oye, si eres un ingeniero de controles educado,
matemáticamente maduro y con fluidez
, entonces no necesitas
que sepas que estos nombres extraños
son en realidad solo formas diferentes de
cortar el mismo pastel.
sabes que todo es un sistema de control es
un sistema de control jerárquico esto es
muy evidente dice en la anatomía y
fisiología que
verás incluso está escribiendo para una
revista de educación en fisiología
y luego comienza a
quejarse de que conoces el
tipo de paja de todos  homeostasis tripulada hasta
este modelo de termostato
y tiene que quejarse así en 2004
porque, de hecho, todo el mundo realmente ha
asociado la palabra homeostasis con
este modelo de termostato.
gran parte de la
teoría de control real se
simplificó, por
lo que incluso como alguien que está alojado en un
departamento de informática  Tomé una clase
sobre el aprendizaje por refuerzo y puedo trabajar con
las ecuaciones de la teoría del control óptimo.
No me presentaron el concepto de una
señal de referencia
como una función variable en el tiempo
hasta Carpenter
y eso fue bastante revelador
para mí, en lugar de tener una
función de error, ¿
quién
eres tú?  conoce el mínimo cuyo mínimo global
es fijo para todo el tiempo
puedes tener una función de error que
mide la diferencia entre tu
trayectoria real
y una trayectoria deseada puedes hacer
un control de seguimiento de la trayectoria cuando
tienes las matemáticas
entonces podríamos decir para nuestro artículo para nuestros
propósitos si  la homeostasis se refiere a este
control de seguimiento del punto de estilo del termostato del termostato,
luego la alostasis se refiere al
control de seguimiento de la trayectoria,
por lo que avanzar un poco y
volver a la pista principal
desde nuestras perspectivas informadas por la
fisiología y la anatomía
y un poco de
interceptación evodivo y alostasis tienen Pro
tienen  ambos
demostraron bastante bien
ser
realmente centrales  a cómo
está realmente estructurado el sistema nervioso
y aparentemente relacionado en gran medida con
el metabolismo y el funcionamiento deficiente
de las vísceras,
por lo que para cualquiera que quiera saber
citas para esto, creo que es
uh Jordan, sería Barrett y quién
2015.
oh uh Barrett y Simmons 2015  Sí,
artículo de neurociencia, sí, revisiones de la naturaleza,
predicciones interceptivas de neurociencia en el cerebro,
hay una revisión más reciente escrita por
Karen Quigley, nuestra otra autora principal
sobre intercepción, salió en 2021
, por lo que realmente puede verificar por
sí mismo y le aconsejaría qué tan
central en  La terrecepción y la regulación visceral
son empíricamente para el sistema nervioso
. Posiblemente podrías diseñar un
sistema nervioso para un robot que funcionara de manera
diferente, pero los que evolucionaron
se centran ubicuamente en mantener la
milia interna del cuerpo eficiente.
si
decidí una pregunta rápida aquí, por supuesto,
sí porque los dos autores aquí
tal vez puedan  solo confirme que mi paracaídas
está empacado correctamente, eso es con lo que
básicamente
quiero sentirme cómodo, así que
retroceda por un segundo
en esa diapositiva y simplemente diríjase
hacia arriba,
la urdimbre y la trama aquí, el tipo
de tejido que usted  Los muchachos estaban trabajando
en este documento: la alostasis y la
enterocepción, esos eran sus puntos focales, ¿
verdad? Y luego ha
pasado bastante tiempo preparándonos
para la diferencia entre el
aspecto de tiempo discreto de lo que está buscando.  en
y la tasa de captura global porque
dices que no podemos, no podemos arreglarnos y solo
el que dice quiero asegurarme de que mi
sesión esté empaquetada correctamente y luego estás
hablando de biología y fisiología, así que
solo en eso en  tan grande
voy a ir a Splat o voy a ser
capaz de aterrizar esto relativamente suavemente puede
usted puede usted tal vez solo
dígame si eso es o no de hecho
es una comparación es una intersección
son estas cosas corriendo en paralelo
cuanto de  esto es gestión de riesgos versus
cuánto de esto es estratégico
, lo consideraría más como
una intersección, está bien, y cuando nos
referimos específicamente a cantidades
como la tasa de captura global,
se pretende que sean estratégicas en
lugar de gestión de riesgos o
valor epistémico,
está bien,
así que  específicamente,
hay un libro completo sobre esto,
digamos um Vigor, la neuroeconomía del
control del movimiento por Reza
Shadmir y narra en forma muy larga y
extensa la evidencia empírica de
que
los organismos reales promediarán su
tasa de recompensa
en el tiempo para pasar de un episódico
ajuste a un
conjunto de control continuo sabes que a un ajuste continuo de por
vida necesitas alguna noción de control de tiempo indefinido
obviamente no vas a vivir hasta que
T sabes que T alcanza el Infinito
pero en el límite necesitas tener un
problema de control coherente
en  al menos para fines de modelado porque
no se puede
arreglar el final de, digamos, la vida de un pájaro
en el laboratorio en una computadora portátil, está bien
y hay dos formas de converger  ncionalmente para
hacer eso, uno es esta noción de
Dios y poner la tasa de captura global
para que el promedio de tiempo sea
la suma de todos los beneficios menos la suma de
todos los costos dividida por la cantidad total de
tiempo
y el otro es un descuento exponencial
ahora para fines de ingeniería
descuento exponencial  hace que las matemáticas
y los cálculos sean mucho más manejables
y, por lo tanto, a principios de la década de 2000,
esencialmente descubrieron que los
verdaderos cerebros reales,
como los ganglios basales y
la activación dopaminérgica,
se ajustan mejor mediante el promedio de tiempo
y luego, en el lado computacional,
todos ignoraron eso e hicieron
descuento exponencial
y, en realidad, cuando hablamos de
algo como una tasa de captura global
, solo decimos que vamos con la
evidencia biológica y escribimos un
modelo que representa mejor los
enlaces empíricos.
en casa, puede
seguir adelante y cambiar al
descuento exponencial
está bien o a la
comunidad de aprendizaje automático  está comenzando a salir con
documentos a tiempo
promediando últimamente los últimos dos años
y esa es una pregunta más rápida, entonces,
por supuesto, sí, gracias por
esa explicación, así que si estamos
planteando la pregunta sobre la
manejabilidad  eso supone que hay
algún tipo de resbaladiza o alguna
pieza de fluidez en esta cosa que
estamos viendo qué qué es eso qué
es esa cosa
que es fluida que es resbaladiza que está
causando que normalmente no podamos
modelar es esa una característica o es  que un
defecto
yo diría que lo resbaladizo es lo
resbaladizo que es el desliz entre el mapa
y el territorio
bien
entonces cuando hablamos de cerebros reales
sabemos que observamos promediar el tiempo
en el territorio
lo que no sabemos hacer es escribir un
algoritmo
que  probablemente produce un promedio de tiempo correcto
y funciona en la práctica en ingeniería,
está
bien, digamos que en lugar de un mapa y un
territorio porque el científico también tiene un
mapa
, digamos que el deslizamiento está entre  En la
ciencia empírica y la ingeniería
, cuando escribimos nuestro modelo,
realmente estamos tratando de abordar la
ciencia empírica y no nos importa si los ingenieros
que conoces quieren hacer su pequeño
desliz y
usar algo que simplemente hace que los
algoritmos sean más fáciles,
eso está bien,
ya sabes.  y, de hecho, eso es lo que la
comunidad de inferencia activa profunda hace
bien, así que retrocede un poco más
hacia la inferencia activa
cuando leemos todo esto, es una
especie de Biblia para nuestro laboratorio
Sterling y Laughlin,
por lo que Simon Laughlin estuvo involucrado en  algunas
de las primeras publicaciones sobre
codificación predictiva en la retina de la mosca
Peter Sterling es el autor del
concepto de alostasis
y lo que realmente notamos,
como se mencionó un poco antes, es este tipo
de deslizamiento, otro deslizamiento o
contradicción,
por lo que dicen cuando obtienes una recompensa.
se libera dopamina,
esto invoca un
algoritmo principal de aprendizaje por refuerzo,
ya sabes, tengamos cuidado con los
circuitos neuronales que no estamos estudiando.  ng en
detalle por el momento
que es Seamos cuidadosos qué tan fuerte es la
declaración que hacemos sobre su función
y luego la mayor parte de la evidencia empírica
que revisan en el libro es sobre la
eficiencia energética de los disparos sensoriales,
por lo que realmente estamos tratando de decir que queremos
pasar de
algo basado en la minimización de una
inferencia variacional del error de predicción
a algo basado
idealmente en un principio de optimización en el
control,
entonces hay algunos argumentos para los
neurocientíficos
que tienen más o menos la intención de
convencer al neurocientífico de Ewing de que las
personas que estudian la intercepción y las personas que
estudian la neurociencia motora
necesita trabajar juntos en el estudio de las
vísceras
no puede estudiar las vísceras e ignorar
la rama motora del sistema nervioso visceral
y las funciones de esa rama motora
ahora con respecto a usted conoce nuestra declaración de
que no puede simplemente minimizar el error de predicción
uno podría preguntarse  que pasa con la inferencia activa
y
ahí hay que empezar a tener cuidado
con el término activo en  inferencia
porque saben, como me lo han
explicado personalmente en detalle,
hay al menos dos
tipos diferentes de inferencia activa,
está este muy antiguo,
um, creo que fue Adams
2013. saben, las predicciones de inferencia activa motora
no ordenan la
inferencia activa en el  motor
que conoce en el sistema motor
y luego está esta noción de inferencia activa de decisión
donde tiene una energía libre esperada
preferencias previas explícitas y así sucesivamente
y si habla con la comunidad de inferencia activa
sabe leer los artículos que pueden
escribir  para su propia comunidad
, les recomendaría especialmente que conozcan
el taller internacional sobre
inferencia activa que creo que será
una conferencia el próximo año.
Tienen tres años de muy buenos
artículos en los que muchos autores esbozan las
conexiones explícitas entre
el control de inferencia activa como inferencia
óptima.  control,
etc.,
así que realmente cuando insistimos en decir que
sabe, no use la inferencia activa para
reducir las funciones motoras  En cuanto a la función sensorial
, estamos hablando con algunos psicólogos y
filósofos
que han estado
, digamos, bastante entusiasmados con el
procesamiento predictivo,
pero un poco eliminativistas con respecto a algunas de
las construcciones matemáticas que
se usan en la inferencia activa,
por lo que para nuestra audiencia de psicólogos
tenemos una vez más  el argumento de que
básicamente estamos
mostrando que puedes y debes hacer
una noción completamente probabilística de
control óptimo para resolver lo que está pasando
con la regulación alostática
y vamos a inspirarnos un poco
en la neuroanatomía motora para hacerlo,
así que
mirando  un sistema de modelo simple
y esto se está convirtiendo en cifras
del artículo
tenemos nuestra curva de respuesta aferente del reflejo de barril
tiene un barorreceptor de zanahoria está en
la arteria carótida en el
cuello mide la presión arterial se
proyecta a un circuito en el
uh NTS en el tronco cerebral
y mencionamos esto aquí porque el
receptor de barril se usa a menudo como modelo
en
terraceptor cuando hablo  d a Karen y le preguntó por
sistemas modelo de intercepción,
ella en realidad dijo que usted sabe bien,
pensemos primero en el receptor de potencia
y otra vez con contradicción,
lo que realmente encontramos al observar la
anatomía es que el barorreceptor, el
receptor del barril carotídeo,
es la rama sensorial de un bajo
circuito de control de nivel, por
lo que el NTS
no tendrá Creo que el
punto de inflexión medio
está codificado en el NTS aquí y realmente no
cambia mucho, pero lo que sucede
es que puede obtener comandos de arriba hacia abajo que
fluyen hacia el MTS
y luego cambiar el  ganancia de este
circuito por
lo que la pendiente de la curva
y si amplía esa pendiente
para que la curva sea menos profunda
que su capacidad de respuesta preservada,
se mantiene, está ampliando la
parte aproximadamente lineal de la
curva
mientras permite que la presión arterial
aumente y  caen
y nuevamente vemos para la intercepción
personas en las
que realmente necesita pensar,
sabe cuál es el papel de este
Interceptor en el control
del cuerpo y  de las vísceras,
no puede simplemente mirarlo y decir que es un
sensor, bueno, está bien, es un sensor dónde se
proyecta TI a la
corteza enteroceptiva, um, no, no
necesariamente como si supiera el error, las
señales de error de predicción que llegan a la
corteza interceptiva
para decir que sabe  No puedo bombear suficiente
sangre o algo así
podría haber sido
procesado por
lo que creo que en la
literatura de inferencia activa motora se llama un
arco
reflejo, por lo que es posible que ya haya un
controlador reflejado que haya operado en
esa señal por el  tiempo llega a las
porciones superiores del cerebro,
por lo que en nuestro artículo presentamos un
vocabulario para que las personas lo usen si
quieren no tener que tener una
curva de capacidad en particular,
lo vincularemos a la noción de la
función de distribución acumulativa.  más adelante
hay alguna terminología de fisiología para las
personas que quieren aprenderla
y luego notamos lo mismo que
Carpenter hace con
Carpenter y una serie de otros documentos,
que es que
esto es un ma  sistema de control fuertemente jerárquico
muchas sustancias reguladas, digamos,
o variables reguladas tendrán
múltiples controladores que las influirán,
por ejemplo,
los niveles de nutrientes en sangre no solo glucosa,
sino que creo que, como el agua salada y
grasa,
están regulados por pares de hormonas, a
veces habrá múltiples pares
de  hormonas por nutriente que tiene que estar
en la sangre
y esto no es una compensación convexa, por lo
que no es una regulación competitiva antagónica
, puede parecer que compiten a veces,
pero en realidad es una regulación cooperativa
basada en el hecho de que, por así decirlo,
las especies químicas no pueden  codificar números negativos de
la forma en que lo hace una señal digital, de
modo que cuando hace cosas con
señales químicas, tener estos pares resulta
ser la forma de
monitorear y controlar el rango dinámico
con la mayor sensibilidad,
como entonces, usando este ejemplo de glucagón
e insulina
, podemos ver  ese tipo de glucemia normal
es realmente más de un rango
y es un rango en el que vas a
tener  respuesta aproximadamente lineal de
la actividad de la insulina
y habrá saturado
o realmente habrá
alcanzado el umbral de actividad del glucagón, por lo que a un nivel normal de azúcar en la sangre, el
glucagón no tiene que recuperar
azúcar en la sangre adicional de los
intestinos o el hígado
no tiene que llamar para quemar grasa
Le reserva esencialmente que ha comido lo suficiente para
el día en que está bien la
insulina responde en un
modo altamente sensible donde puede dar una
respuesta lineal a un cambio lineal
para compensar el ruido
así que ahora podemos acercarnos a usted,
ahora que tenemos una forma de controlar la
fisiología
, podemos acercarnos más a estas nociones de
inferencia activa
y aquí vamos a volver a algunas
de las
fuentes que nos dieron motor activo  inferencia
una forma de pensar sobre la inferencia activa motora
es
el sentido cerebral de predicción
el arco reflejo en la médula espinal
intenta minimizar el error de predicción
comparando la predicción con el  El
valor se lee de un propioceptor,
por lo que nuevamente, una forma de pensar en eso
es tener algunas formas adicionales de minimizar el
error de predicción, realmente la entropía,
otra forma de pensar en eso
es pensar en tener un
sistema de control muy elemental en el nivel del arco reflejo
y luego  el cerebro prescribe la
longitud de referencia que es la
señal de referencia para ese controlador
y simplemente trata de minimizar la
diferencia entre lo que obtiene de un
propioceptor lo que lee la
longitud y la tensión muscular real
y la señal de referencia
y esto es en realidad muy I I  Casi lo
llamaría un circuito divertido de estudiar
debido a lo bien documentado que
está
que hay algo muy parecido
, casi diría como un
controlador PID ponderado de precisión allí
, sabes, si eres una persona matemática, entonces un
músculo es amable.  de como un resorte de
resorte puede ser usted conoce la dinámica de
un resorte de
metal de resorte estirarlo y
crujirlo sabe que se puede linealizar alrededor de
ciertos puntos
y usted puede ju  Primero escriba
un controlador LTI PID como requisito
para un huso muscular individual
y obtendrá dos parámetros que
bajan del cerebro, uno de los cuales dice
la longitud de referencia
y el otro dice que sabe
cuál es la sensibilidad o la ganancia contra la
perturbación.  que debe hacer ejercicio
y así es como
se involucran sus movimientos voluntarios,
así que realmente
todo esto sobre las referencias de las que
estamos
hablando aquí solo presenta la
hipótesis de
que tal vez el control motor visceral funciona
con los mismos principios computacionales y anatómicos
que  el control somatomotor voluntario,
por supuesto, en lugar de los comandos que
provienen de la corteza somatomotora
, podrían provenir de los ganglios en el
sistema nervioso autónomo
con el sistema nervioso central de nivel superior
básicamente prescribiendo niveles aproximados
de activación o desactivación de actividad
para los dos lados diferentes del
sistema nervioso autónomo
que luego de nuevo en esta forma opuesta
se  La forma totalmente cooperativa de mi oponente
nos permite evitar la codificación de
números negativos digitales y, por lo tanto, le brinda
un control muy equilibrado sobre la
milia interna
para que finalmente lleguemos a nuestra figura
que esencialmente dice
si sé qué recurso suministra.
tipo de cosas
que voy a tener en el futuro,
entonces mi objetivo será
, no digamos, maximizar la incertidumbre
ni minimizar la incertidumbre, sino
realmente maximizar la resiliencia o la libertad,
permanecer en la parte lineal de una
función de distribución acumulativa
donde puede estar  responde
a cualquier perturbación restante o próxima,
por lo que aquí dibujamos que puede hacer que
este estimador de capacidad
cierre el ciclo
y comience a dirigir las acciones motoras a través de
la inferencia
activa para seguir esta preferencia por la
resiliencia contra la perturbación de la
milia interna
que luego es  ligado a la estimación de estado interceptivo
sus otros estimadores de estado su a
los servicios de servicio sensorial reales
y todo este diagrama de cableado
y tal vez una cosa para agregar demasiado
bien solo para subrayar un punto es
que creo que si retrocede una diapositiva
aquí
y cómo se relaciona esto con
el tipo de rango adaptativo del
asentamiento  Señale también y lo que creo que es
realmente interesante sobre este derecho es
que
no está definiendo
como cuando comenzamos a hablar sobre
cómo podría pensar tradicionalmente sobre los
puntos de referencia para la homeostasis en un
modelo de termostato muy tradicional, justo de
lo que está hablando.  aquí está que
en realidad hay
[Música]
um
si el objetivo general del cerebro si el
cerebro está esencialmente allí para ayudar a
regular y adaptarse a una especie de
sistema biológico completo del cuerpo a
circunstancias externas que
cambiarán constantemente
diferentes desafíos  que va
a tener que responder,
entonces no necesariamente tiene un
punto fijo, pero tiene un rango
donde puede estar la fisiología  más
adaptable a esas perturbaciones y
desafíos, ¿verdad?
Incluso creo que para simplificar una
especie de creo que esa idea es
realmente el núcleo de lo que estamos tratando de hablar
sobre la radio, así que esencialmente
quieres tener um
arreglar dónde está el  la fisiología puede ser
adaptativa y sí, te imaginas que
si la fisiología es si algunos de estos
parámetros se empujan mucho más
allá del centro de ese sigmoide,
entonces vas a tener un problema
porque no podrán
adáptate a los cambios, no
podrás estar en ese punto lineal de
Máxima adaptabilidad si estás
cerca del umbral
y conoces un ruido blanco aleatorio
que te empuja sobre ese
umbral,
obviamente allí  no es una
falla catastrófica discreta,
pero también, obviamente, ya no puede
montar una respuesta proporcional,
sí,
su cuerpo está hecho de
instrumentos físicos que tienen
un rango limitado de capacidad de respuesta,
sí, por lo que nuestra noción o  f alostasis
es decir
cuándo puede
ampliar el rango de capacidad de respuesta en
lugar de reducirlo
o más bien ampliar el rango de
capacidad de respuesta cuando sea posible mientras
reduce el conjunto de estados o la
distribución de estados en los que realmente
cae, sí,
sí, y entonces parece que lo está haciendo.  cosas un tanto
opuestas
y, por lo tanto, ¿sería el caso
correcto que podría tener um,
hay diferentes maneras en que puede hacer que
estos sistemas se vuelvan algo inadaptados
si eso si eso es si ese lineal
si ese sigmoide se vuelve más y
más inclinado y más inclinado donde básicamente
es solo un rango muy muy estrecho
en el que en realidad puede tener una
respuesta adaptativa que puede ser un
problema potencial, otro problema potencial puede ser
cuando el tipo de nivel de referencia como
usted dice se empuja mucho más allá de
ese umbral,
entonces también está  va a requerir mucho
más trabajo y muchos más controles o
mucho más control de ese sistema necesario
para realmente empujarlo más allá de ese
rango  e realmente adaptarse para empujarlo hacia atrás
realmente para empujarlo hacia atrás de nuevo, sí, lo
que podría causar otros problemas
aguas abajo también, pero el
punto es que usted, um,
el tipo de rango en el que desea que este
sistema se asiente es un rango
donde puede adaptarse a los cambios
y prepararse para
circunstancias fluctuantes,
sí, así
que creo que una buena intuición para partir,
ya que estamos llegando al final
de la hora,
es que
si tratara de minimizar la
incertidumbre interceptiva
, ¿entonces qué?  lo que podrías hacer es quedarte en casa
todo el tiempo,
tu frecuencia cardíaca nunca variará demasiado
hacia arriba y hacia abajo
y estamos viviendo en el mundo moderno
donde no tienes que huir de los
Tigres para que sepas por qué lidiar con la
incertidumbre de  salir y hacer ejercicio
o la perturbación de salir y
hacer ejercicio
y lo que nuestra noción de alostasis aquí
podría decirle en respuesta
es que
cuando sale y hace ejercicio, la curva
se ensancha
y, por lo tanto, el rango adaptativo donde  puede
montar una respuesta proporcional que
se amplíe,
así que salga y haga ejercicio porque en
realidad aumenta su resistencia a la
fisiología para el desafío fisiológico futuro,
por
lo que todavía está dentro del
conjunto de intuiciones de inferencia activa, pero realmente estamos
asumiendo esta suposición de
que debe prepararse de forma preventiva
contra un posible desafío en
lugar de
efectivo en lugar de actuar para evitar un
posible desafío
hemos movido el manejo del desafío
al cuerpo
uh Dean adelante
mientras llegas a esos extremos de esos
momentos de crisis hablamos un
poco sobre esto en el punto cero  ¿Cómo
cambia la interacción o la proporción de instrucción
entre algo que es interactivo y un
rango que busca
volver a entrar? Tengo curiosidad
si los formalismos cambian a medida que
se alcanzan esos extremos porque,
como dijiste, las cosas no suceden.  t siempre se
vuelve
catastrófico eres irreversiblemente
catastróficamente
um
stat entonces, ¿qué te gustaría en función de
lo que y  Ustedes, obviamente, han analizado
cuál es su opinión acerca de
cómo cambia la relación entre la
interacción y la instrucción a medida que
llegamos a esos límites realmente difíciles.
uh, Jordan, a menudo eres un poco mejor
en fisiología que yo. ¿Quieres
tomar esto o
oh?  no, no estoy seguro, creo que podrías
tenerlo,
así
que veamos
, sinceramente, no soy tan bueno en fisiología
porque confío en Karen para eso
, casi diría que hay una
falla en el territorio del mapa aquí
donde estábamos tratando de modelar así que  para
hablar de función normal
bajo
función normal con esa intuición
sobre la resiliencia contra el desafío, está bien,
y hay varias respuestas posibles
a una circunstancia extrema,
ya sabes, una es que algún
mecanismo de control
superior puede comenzar a anular estos
puntos
operativos alejándolos de donde
normalmente están y  entonces eso le permite
lidiar con
circunstancias extremas al no
tratarlas más como errores,
así que digamos que si está enfermo,
la temperatura central de su cuerpo es  modulada
hacia arriba que lo pone en un estado febril,
esto es metabólicamente costoso y se
siente mal en comparación con la
forma en que funciona normalmente, pero debería
cocinar los gérmenes
y luego, cuando llegue al estado extremo, sabrá
cuándo se terminará esa emergencia
supuestamente con suerte, por lo general
podrá  para volver a la función normal,
por supuesto, hay excepciones, como
decir long covet right
solo para asegurarse de que vea
un cambio en la cantidad de
comandos literales y la cantidad de ida y
vuelta a medida que se acerca a esos límites
¿verdad?  creo que simplemente se dan cuenta de
que se están acercando cada vez
más a
un punto de caída
. Creo que en realidad es una pregunta abierta y
empírica, de acuerdo, una de las
razones por las que nos gusta llegó a
escribir un modelo matemático completo.  en
este documento
es porque a menudo
no hay mucho
trabajo neurocomputacional empírico sobre la
intercepción, por lo que si hace preguntas muy
básicas como si la
intercepción se codifica de manera predecible  bajo
el cuello,
esa es todavía una pregunta abierta
, podría ser que los
pterosceptores periféricos solo estén transduciendo una
señal de estímulo
y luego solo se codifique de manera predecible
cuando llegue al cerebro que aún no sabemos,
por lo que preferimos tener algún
Eli perdido brevemente.  lo he perdido, pero está bien,
mientras Eli se reincorpora, está bien, muy
interesante,
un camino diferente a
través del mismo material,
Dave, si tu pregunta es para Eli, podemos
esperar unos segundos,
no necesariamente,
um, solo tengo un comentario adicional
, no necesariamente tienes que responder a
esto.  la discusión me recuerda a dos
falacias diferentes, una es la falacia del cuarto oscuro,
ya sabes, si quieres
minimizar, es una especie de parodia de la inferencia activa,
si no quieres serlo, si
no quieres que te sorprendan, simplemente
quédate  en una habitación oscura donde nada
cambia, lo que ha sido descartado bastante a
fondo por los activistas de seguros activos,
también hubo una
especie de falacia de una interpretación teñida de oscuridad social
de la observación de
que  Cada especie tiene un número fijo de
latidos del corazón y, por lo tanto, las personas valiosas, los
miembros del parlamento y los
clérigos, no trabajaron porque te estás comiendo
toda la vida, lo cual, por supuesto
, no es cierto porque tu corazón
late más lentamente, por lo que está estirado.
más si estás en buena forma, ¿verdad?
pero más relevante,
um, la inclinación de la curva refleja. A
veces siento que las personas que trabajan en
cobertura de inferencia activa pueden ser demasiado con la noción de
precisión, es decir, esta es una cantidad
y parece que la  esa pendiente en la
curva de presión arterial, pero eso podría
ser algo que tendería a estar
cubierto por el término precisión y, de ser así,
debería ser una proporción de una manera más
diferenciada en lugar de
ser solo un número único que se aplica en
montones y montones de  áreas de control y
percepción
que son interesantes, por
lo que normalmente la Precisión correcta se
aplica normalmente a las predicciones, por lo
que hay una idea de
la Precisión de la predicción.  ciones que se están
aplicando y, en este caso, creo que
la idea es más de um,
por lo que vuelve a donde,
uh, podría estar hablando de preferencias previas que
se apuntan en
modelos de inferencia activa,
um, y creo que la pendiente de la
curva de respuesta es en cambio  tratando
de apuntar a ese uso de las preferencias previas
correctamente, por
lo que está tratando de apuntar específicamente a dónde
está, um,
dónde está tratando de
navegar el sistema, ha sido
sí, cuando las personas hablan sobre las
preferencias anteriores, a veces lo han dicho
en términos de que
el sistema tiene  una especie de fuerte anterior
fuertes y precisos previos que se codifican
um
como a priori anterior se codifica uh
para ser objetivo
y en este caso creo que es um
estamos tratando de dar cuenta de dónde
pueden provenir algunos de esos anteriores y
cómo estos  los sistemas y cómo los
procesos oponentes
pueden o los químicos oponentes pueden ayudar a
regular la fisiología
y estamos tratando de obtener un enfoque más natural
de dónde pueden surgir,
así que
bu  t
Creo, um,
si se reemplaza, solo estoy tratando de
pensar en hablar en voz alta para pensar en la
pregunta, de modo que
si está reemplazando básicamente una preferencia anterior
y, um,
si normalmente esa preferencia anterior
sería manejada por uh
una especie de cuenta de precisión de
entonces, hasta cierto punto,
la inclinación de esa curva está tratando de
abordar, uh, es algo así como un reemplazo
de Precision, pero
um,
pero sí,
uh, está dando una
forma diferente de, um,
sí, tal vez sea un reemplazo para la
posición en eso  caso de que
Eli haya regresado, así que tal vez pueda intentar
responder a tu pregunta, Eli, ¿quieres
completar tu presentación?
um, claro, pero si solo para responder a la
pregunta, si estamos hablando de la ganancia
en una de estas curvas de signoide,
entonces
sí, eso es una especie de  Reemplazo de
la precisión, pero realmente está
pensando en pensar en todo lo
contrario, por
lo que una variación cuantifica su tolerancia
al error.
Una precisión o una ganancia cuantifican la
respuesta al error.
Sí,
sí, entonces.  cuando estás hablando de señales puramente
sensoriales,
estas señales receptivas adicionales,
las que no te prescriben
referencias de ninguna manera,
entonces, por supuesto, sabes que quieres guardar
la respuesta neuronal, que es
metabólicamente costosa
para señales precisas
si estás hablando de  una
curva fisiológica interna,
digamos, una reacción a un cambio en la
presión arterial,
entonces quiere intentar
hacer que la ganancia sea menos profunda, quiere
tolerar la variación, lo
siento,
eh,
obtuve mi módem doméstico, creo que se
reinició solo sin razón aparente, lo
llamamos un  ciclo de sueño-vigilia
sí
um qué tal si hizo algunas
actualizaciones de gradiente de fase de sueño
pero es más simple está actualizado
um está listo para que completes la
presentación y luego
volveremos muy um interesante aunque
así que
está bien
um
ver compartir pantalla aquí estamos bien
continuar
sí, así que ahora empezamos a analizar
realmente qué escaso
material visual está disponible para la
sección cuatro,
que creo que tendremos que analizar en
detalle en un  más q un formato un poco,
pero si luego queremos hablar sobre cómo
integramos la inferencia activa de decisiones
en esta vista alostática,
entonces podemos decir que la toma de decisiones es esta
noción de control de control óptimo
sujeto a un conjunto de expectativas sobre
el futuro
para que podamos  Tendremos que escribir una función objetiva
y luego recuperaremos nuestro diagrama de cableado
y notaremos que las referencias de motor
emitidas de arriba hacia abajo
ahora están condicionadas o sujetas a
predicciones sobre el futuro,
entonces parte de cómo vamos a obtener  en
lo que realmente se compone esta función objetivo
es Primero tomar la intuición de
que si comenzamos con circuitos neuronales
que solo pueden hacer procesamiento predictivo
tal como lo conocemos,
entonces una cosa que podemos hacer con ellos
es simular algún Conjunto o
población
de
trayectorias de estado potencial o trayectorias de
acción de estado real a
partir de algún estado inicial,
entonces, dada una función objetivo
, podemos estimar el promedio de tiempo
dado nuestro sentido  mble
, podemos convertir eso en control de retroalimentación
obteniendo la estabilidad en la teoría de control,
la estabilidad de ciclo cerrado derivada del
uso de retroalimentación
al tener un modelo de reconocimiento
y luego podemos decir ah
, voy a actualizar todo mi conjunto
o población
de
simulaciones tomándolas  del modelo de reconocimiento
que está condicionado a
los resultados sensoriales observados
y luego tener predicciones de la
densidad de reconocimiento
que estamos superponiendo aquí con
superíndice, también sabes paréntesis
en comparación con los paréntesis de superíndice
uno aquí
, podemos penalizar una noción de
distancia,
así que realmente podemos  penalice el
tamaño entre comillas de la actualización
en términos teóricos de la información
y si ha visto una energía libre o una
energía libre esperada escrita término por
término antes de
que debería haber visto uno de estos, es una
Divergencia KL,
pero lo que eso nos da es
control estabilizado por retroalimentación
utilizando modelos de probabilidad
y que en realidad llega más o menos
al final de las diapositivas por  Entonces,
como algunos puntos de resumen
son un modelo computacional,
nos brinda una noción útil de la competencia de asequibilidad
,
básicamente, ejecute un montón de simulaciones hacia adelante,
elija las que van a tener
buenos valores esperados a lo largo del tiempo, promediando
para representar realmente
como referencias
del motor las
curvas sigmoidales.
después de que hayamos tomado sus derivados para
convertirlos en densidades de probabilidad
, entonces tomamos el logaritmo de
esos para convertirlos en densidades logarítmicas, lo
cual es mucho más típico porque sabe que
la inferencia activa como una preferencia previa logarítmica en
realidad proporciona una noción de
moneda
extranjera común  porque ahora hemos normalizado,
conoce toda la noción de probabilidad Masa a
uno,
por lo que una densidad sobre una variable y una
densidad sobre la otra variable tienen las
mismas unidades
, no necesitamos más noción de una
moneda de recompensa en este modelo,
entonces hay algunos  aliento
para que los anatomistas y fisiólogos
digan
, vamos a ver la regulación motora autonómica y visceral
y ver si  podemos entenderlo
en términos de estos circuitos de control de motor
en el nivel bajo
y eso nos lleva a conocer algunas
conclusiones muy generales;
idealmente, nuestro trabajo debe ponerse en
diálogo con la inferencia activa
como trabajo de control de otros autores
y, por supuesto, agradecimientos.  realmente pueden
ver aquí cuánto trabajo se dedicó a
esto en nombre de absolutamente todos
los miembros del equipo
y las referencias,
así que dejaré de compartir y podemos cambiar a
un formato más interactivo,
genial,
gracias por
compartir eso y, entonces, ¿dónde se
compartió anteriormente?  en qué contexto,
um, solo en el contexto de nuestro grupo de laboratorio
, está bien, así que vamos a deslizar el grupo de la Facultad de
Ingeniería, estábamos hablando, sí,
sí, así que las diapositivas están realmente hechas para
esto, como la
psicología de los biólogos con un
grupo de algunos ingenieros.
muchos,
muchos caminos, muchos caminos por recorrer
solo para resaltar algunas piezas
bajo este
amplio paraguas de fisiología, un
punto importante que
planteaste fue cuánto
hom  eostasis la
misma
estasis
está en efecto versus un mecanismo de
realidad es que la estabilización a veces
empíricamente de la estasis
e incluso la homeostasis
es eso bajo Lane por un impulso a un
punto establecido como se ha simplificado o
entendido como en ese
modelo de termómetro simple y luego en qué medida
¿Incluimos la alostasis, la hormesis, la excitación
y diferentes fenómenos fisiológicos
y los consideramos parte de los
compromisos homeostáticos dinámicos y multimodales de los cuerpos complejos
frente a
descartar lo viejo y lo nuevo y
cuánto agrupar y dividir la fisiología cuando
incluso en el celular único?  nivel de forma de vida
, están participando
desde una perspectiva teórica computacional o de control o
información en
procesos que son análogos a algunos de
estos,
ese es un punto que podemos explorar,
otra área para explorar es
sobre el tema de qué están haciendo estos sistemas
y cómo lo hacemos.  modelarlo el territorio del mapa
o la
pregunta de investigación básica de ingeniería de um
podríamos hablar de un determinado
proceso fisiológico
estabilización de la temperatura corporal o el barorreceptor la
glucosa y así sucesivamente
¿existe la minimización de una
diferencia,
por ejemplo, entre lo preferido y lo
observado?
¿existe una maximización de la recompensa?
De acuerdo con alguna función de recompensa,
¿existe una maximización de la precisión?
de responsividad
que corresponde en la
familia de curvas sigmoidales a la región linealizada
¿hay casos en los que estas cuatro
cosas van a suceder
indistinguiblemente
¿hay un caso en el que algunos de estos
fenómenos están ocurriendo en detrimento
de otros
podemos diferenciar modelos y realmente
hacer predicciones únicas, explicaciones y
sistemas de control
si movemos nuestro énfasis de una de
estas lentes a otra lente
y cómo deberíamos pensar en diferentes
sistemas fisiológicos que van desde los
mecanismos implícitos y muy antiguos
hasta aquellos que conscientemente pueden incluso sentirse
como, por ejemplo, recompensa de minimización de errores
maximización
maximización de la precisión maximización de la capacidad de respuesta
así que me
detendré allí y cualquiera de los autores puede hacer
algunos comentarios o cualquiera puede plantear una
pregunta o pensar
Eli Solo quería preguntarte tal vez solo
para dirigir dentro de esto porque
al final hablaste sobre
que esto nos atrapa  lejos de
tener que tener una moneda de recompensa,
oh sí, y tal vez me interesaría si
pudieras dar más detalles sobre eso,
así
que, ¿cuál sería el papel típico de una
moneda de recompensa y cómo funciona
este tipo de cómo funciona el  marco
que está proponiendo cambiar eso,
sí, así que realmente retrocedería y diría que
sabe qué cambios, este es el
punto de vista de inferencia activa, así que cite
entre comillas típicamente si está haciendo
algo como
um si es alguien como  Yale Neve o
Sam Gershman, entonces piensas en la recompensa
como en términos de aprendizaje de refuerzo como
algo que el cerebro tiene que maximizar
y luego dirías que está bien,
quiero que
la incertidumbre de mis creencias se
minimice.  mientras maximizo la recompensa,
entonces esos son dos cálculos modulares separados
que tienen objetivos casi opuestos,
uno de ellos es minimizar la
incertidumbre en este momento y el otro
es maximizar la recompensa a largo plazo
y los ingresos, sabes, inferencia activa
y realmente dice no, no si  exprese esto
como un problema de optimización variacional,
entonces puede obtener un objetivo unificado para
esto
donde sabe que la moneda común es, por
así decirlo,
evidencia de que
realmente sabe evidencia de que está
siguiendo la trayectoria correcta
evidencia de que está ejecutando una
operación de comportamiento correcto
y las series de evidencia que conoces en términos de
supongo que los llamaríamos mosquitos o bits
son las unidades y la teoría de la información, por
lo que si estás usando
sabes e como la base de tu
logaritmo,
entonces no lo es si estás usando una base log 2
son partes que
mis perros están siendo recogidos para sus
paseos, así que
sí, esta es una perspectiva complementaria muy interesante
en la que obtendremos la maximización de la recompensa con el
tiempo
cuando
aumentemos o  ur Precision ahora todos están de
acuerdo en eso y va a ser el
carro antes que el caballo o el caballo
antes que el carro y cuál es el caballo
y cuál es el carro
y enmarcar la función objetivo unificada
en términos teóricos de la información
como una heurística delimitadora sorpresa como  se
ha hecho en los límites inferiores de la evidencia bayesiana
durante mucho tiempo al enmarcar el
límite de minimización de sorpresas como la
función objetivo unificada y la moneda,
luego está el
mantenimiento realizado de la homeostasis o como
queramos llamarlo
sin necesidad de una
maximización de la recompensa estructurada tradicionalmente como se define por  una función de
recompensa o recompensa con descuento de tiempo
y también es muy interesante, como
si no estuviéramos tratando de acumular
temperatura corporal, no intentáramos
acumular glucosa
si estuviéramos jugando un juego en el que simplemente
más puntos eran mejores,
como algo social y subsocial  juegos,
entonces una optimización unilateral a través de la
maximización Paradigma tiene mucho
sentido,
pero por el tipo de ph
juegos infinitos psicológicos que jugamos
como usted destacó con el Horizonte infinito,
entonces puede tener más
sentido tener una responsabilidad limitada
y un énfasis en la capacidad de control
bajo los antecedentes heredados de que esos
rangos controlables son los
rangos sobrevivientes, de lo contrario, ¿cómo podría uno haber
existido durante Generaciones en
lugar de  tratar de
acumular glucosa,
sí, así que creo
que siempre es muy interesante volver
atrás y leer a Peter Sterling bajo esta
luz
porque
sabes que más allá del
material fisiológico formal,
hay estas historias que él puede contar,
por ejemplo, de personas que viven en
situaciones estresantes a largo plazo.  situaciones
y desarrollan lo que ahora llamaríamos
las enfermedades de la civilización
que, como sabes, Sterling
implica que son las enfermedades de la homeostasis
vivir demasiado igual demasiado
tiempo
y, de hecho, hablando de que sabes que no
quieres acumular glucosa,
esto es  que sabes que esta es una
enfermedad real que le sucede a las personas que se
llama
diabetes  se considera una patología y, por lo tanto,
hay
casi un interesante desajuste
entre esa noción intuitiva de recompensa
o al
menos burlándonos un poco y digamos esa
noción económica de recompensa
que tiene que ser una forma de acumulación de
riqueza en una moneda común
frente a la fisiología en la que también  gran parte de algo
bueno es en realidad algo malo otra vez, ¿
verdad? Y eso realmente vuelve
a que si hay una parte de lo que esto está
contribuyendo, entonces en cierto modo es una
especie de cambio en la metáfora, ¿verdad? O
creo que ese punto sobre un
una concepción económica y el valor y la
recompensa
es útil tener un contrapunto a
eso porque, como dice Eli,
no hay un límite superior para la recompensa económica,
hay un beneficio para
acumularla, piensa en acumular
capital para gastarlo,
um
en este caso  correcto, en lo que nos estamos
enfocando es en
cómo
básicamente mantenernos equilibrados y adaptables
para que los desafíos futuros puedan ser
realmente enfrentados y manejados y
que en algún momento  s significa empacar poco y no
tener tanta glucosa a la mano para que
puedas lidiar con la recompensa
o lidiar con circunstancias cambiantes y
adaptarte a ellas,
pero no puedes,
um, en realidad es tal vez sí,
tal vez ha sido un problema bastante serio para
tienen esta
noción de valor completamente abstracta de
que
um
es infinitamente acumulable y en
realidad
no interactúa con ninguna de las
realidades biológicas de um
de lo que los sistemas realmente están
haciendo, sí, es tan
abstracto que es
um, es  va a ser muy difícil
interactuar con Biología,
sí, antes de pasar a la pregunta,
digamos que resumamos eso diciendo que las
cuentas bancarias no tienen límites y son
útiles porque no tienen límites,
ya sabes, la cuenta como un economista
puede concebir billones de  dólares en
activos
de una manera que mi cuerpo no puede los
cuerpos están limitados
si sabes que están
limitados físicamente están hechos de una cantidad finita
de materia a la vez
si sabes  trate de poner mucho más en
ellos, algo malo sucederá
naturalmente después de configurar esto en esa
discusión del canal.
realmente interesado en ver a dónde
va esta conversación, así que me pondré al día con
los centros, gracias,
está bien, gracias,
si a nadie le importa, me gustaría hacerle su pregunta a Dave
primero solo porque estaba a punto de
hacerlo cuando me echaron,
sí, adelante.  es Dave
o um es ese que dije
um sí sé cuál era
um si tienes una nueva pregunta está bien
yo oh sí eso es probablemente mejor um
sus dos
piezas de civilización existe el
rumor y tal vez esto fue solo una falacia
o un malentendido de que las personas que
lograron permanecer en Londres durante el
bombardeo en condiciones que uno
esperaría producirían una cantidad masiva de síndromes de conversión de
histeria de enfermedades psicosomáticas psicosomáticas
que no
sucedieron, las personas estaban absurdamente
cuerdas porque lo hicieron  no tuvieron tiempo para
enfermarse no tuvieron tiempo para volverse
locos eso realmente
sucedió el sentido de la misión anuló lo que de
otro modo habría sido el
síndrome de estrés general causando averías
um alguien sabe la
historia detallada del London Blitz en el mundo  War
II porque realmente no lo sé, es un gran
uh no English dot 1.5
um Journey para que exploremos, pero para
hablar de eso en general,
también es una pregunta interesante hasta
qué punto al consolar y
regularizar
incluso trabajamos en contra de eso y mucho menos.
descuidar otras compensaciones e incurrir en
externalidades
um Dean
Eli esto ha sido fantástico yo así que esto es
lo mío
um y yo tal vez en el en el punto
dos entraremos en el yo que
mencioné al final del punto  cero,
esperaba que realmente tuvieras unos
guantes de terciopelo para guiarme a través
del 4.4 porque
y especialmente después del contexto que nos has
podido brindar hoy en torno a la
idea de que
[Música]
um
, conoces a ingenieros y psicólogos
entró en una habitación ahora, no sé si
una vez que entró en esa habitación, se
convirtió en una intersección con luz roja,
luz verde y ustedes jugaron
un Red Rover, vengan sobre cosas o el
clima y lo saben muy bien
aquí está  la cosa porque en realidad
trabajé con directores financieros e ingenieros, y
lo que descubres es que hay un poco de
isomorfismo. Quiero poder diagramar
esto para que veas que eso tiende a
ser sesgado para los ingenieros y luego está
el espacio envuelto.  visión del
psicólogo como si estuvieran en su
espacio fenomenológico y lo que has
hecho
es que has tratado de decir qué qué cuando
esos dos mundos se juntan No
sé si es una colisión No sé
si es  una cooperación, es una variedad de
cosas, es complicado, lo
dejaremos ahí, pero mi pregunta es
esta, cuando llegué a 4.4, sentí que
estaba esquiando, pasé de un hermoso
campo de polvo a algunos
árboles de escasa distancia a Tighter  y más apretado
y fino  Por cierto, pensé que no sé cómo
puedo seguir adelante porque no
parece haber más brechas aquí, simplemente
se está poniendo demasiado apretado para mí y la
reconciliación como cuando estás esquiando
como una metáfora es que no estás  mirando
los árboles
, estás mirando la no
cosa, son los no objetos, es una
Reconciliación
y cuando estamos hablando de dodgeball
como tu metáfora o si estamos
hablando de
glucagón controla esto para mí lo que
estabas describiendo  hasta ese punto,
esencialmente usted estaba diciendo que
supiéramos qué está pasando, vamos a
ver la gestión de riesgos, vamos a
ver la coordinación, vamos a
ver esas cosas que son
esencialmente retrospectivas, podemos  decir
que para que el proceso
continúe, tiene que
abordarse esos factores y
luego tiene que haber una reconciliación,
como cuando los ingenieros y los
psicólogos están próximos entre
sí, es un enredo
y no lo es  a los ingenieros pueden decirles a los
psicólogos qué hacer más de lo que
los psicólogos pueden decirles a los
ingenieros qué hacer bien, así
que
si la pieza de comportamiento si la idea de
la biología y la fisiología es si
hago esto ahora en términos reales
tengo que mirar eso y ustedes tenían
un L4 diferentes marcos de tiempo, ¿
verdad? Puedo manejar que hablaron
claramente sobre eso.
luego
llegué a 4.4
y simplemente perdí el hilo porque
lo que estaba buscando era la
reconciliación. Alinearé este próximo
movimiento con el recapitulador de rango, eso es
lo que esperaba a continuación y luego me
fue bien. Entonces, ¿dónde está la estrategia
porque ahí está?  cuando cuando los
psicólogos y los ingenieros entran en una
habitación no solo abandonan su
estrategia, viene con ellos, los
sigue a ese espacio y los lleva a
esa pregunta de reconcilio
una ventaja y todo lo anterior hasta que
Elijo esta Elección manteniendo siempre
todo lo anterior, así que hablaron
sobre eso en otras partes y dijeron
que no podemos simplemente abandonarlo,
pero no pude entender cómo el
formalismo lo
concilió,
así que lamento que sea tan largo.
-pregunta sin aliento pero papel fotográfico, oh, es
increíble pasar seis horas de mi vida
yendo, estos muchachos tienen que estar mucho
más cerca de responder esto porque
nunca he podido responderlo, pero luego
me perdí y me sentí como oh hombre
¿Qué me estoy perdiendo? De
acuerdo, lo
decepcionaré un poco y le
diré que sabe que lo que se está perdiendo es que
creo que lo que falta en nuestra escritura
es dejar en claro que estamos trabajando
bajo un conjunto muy inusual
de restricciones en la forma en que  formuló
este modelo
tan específicamente a diferencia de
Sam Gershman Oriel Leave
o a diferencia de la literatura sobre inferencia activa profunda
en computadoras
, asumimos que esencialmente
no necesita
un conjunto adicional de
ingredientes computacionales para el aprendizaje de refuerzo,
por lo que estamos diciendo  suponiendo que solo puede realizar
las
operaciones computacionales que se sabe que están
involucradas en el procesamiento predictivo,
¿qué se le ocurre que
manejará un problema de control
y la respuesta es esta cosa muy específica
con estas derivaciones desagradablemente involucradas
llamadas control integral de ruta
y notará  que cuando estaba
repasando esas diapositivas, básicamente dije,
digamos que puedes simular
, conoces futuros
posibles, como posibles cursos de duración de episodios,
conoces cursos de actividad futura
y puedes evaluarlos en términos de
tu función objetivo
y luego puedes actualizarlos por  por medio de
un modelo de reconocimiento
o mediante la integración de errores de predicción y el
uso de codificación predictiva,
entonces, ¿cómo construimos un formalismo a partir
de esos
y la ventaja es que esto nos permite
ver la literatura de controles y decir que está
bien,
esto es en realidad
un control óptimo estabilizado por retroalimentación?
podemos mirar algo de la
literatura de racionalidad limitada
en la ciencia cognitiva y la neurociencia
y sa  su función objetivo es una energía libre,
es decir,
si tiene que penalizar cuánto
cambia el disparo neuronal
con el tiempo
o cuánto cambia de opinión y
actualiza sus creencias con el tiempo
porque solo tiene tanto
poder metabólico en su cabeza,
entonces incluimos  un término de penalización por eso
y podemos decir que todo esto se puede hacer simplemente
mediante la simulación incorporada y
el control del motor de configuración de referencia
¿significa eso que así es como el cerebro
realmente hace las cosas, por supuesto,
no sabes, significa que si
quieres hacer  tu modelado con
creo que
Andy Clark tiende a citar que conoces a
Quine y dice que si quieres hacerlo si
te gustan los paisajes desérticos,
entonces te hemos dado un modelo computacional
que es básicamente rocas lijadas
y, como tal, sí, es algo  de un
entorno hostil
, sabes caminar sin ritmo, no
restarás valor al gusano
en los planos de activo,
sí, si quieres vivir detrás del
muro de escudos donde tenemos,
um
TD, el valor estimado funciona bien  para
usted
en el sigmoide estirado con amplia
variabilidad, tan estirado que es plano
y simple, pero todavía altamente
controlable dentro de grandes límites,
ahí es donde estamos oscilando,
sí,
muy interesante, creo que será genial
en nuestro laboratorio para recoger algunos puntos.  de
soy yo el que corta de
nuevo todavía te veo
sí está bien sí estás de vuelta bien
parpadeaste un poco bien
um en los últimos minutos podemos
hablar sobre algunas ideas de antes en
el periódico mira cualquiera de las figuras y
luego, en el punto dos, sería increíble
abordar realmente el formalismo y
ayudar a Dean en ese viaje de esquí,
um,
¿qué sería algo a lo que ir en
estos últimos minutos?
para elaborar con un
poco más de Jordan en el próximo,
pero tengo curiosidad por saber si te esforzaste
y genial en Great Lengths para decir mira,
esto no se relaciona directamente con todas las
complejidades que sabemos que existen, pero ¿
por qué dijiste?  empezar en esto en
20  19 usted tenía un poco de tiempo en sus manos
y luego y luego aludió a
esto al principio
hubo descubrimientos
que hizo que no anticipó
porque usted también fue muy um muy
respetuoso en quién reconoció como una
especie de  sentando las bases
aquí, tenía un poco de estabilidad con la que trabajar,
pero ¿se encontró con que
le presentaron cosas
que no estaban allí antes de que ustedes se
unieran en torno a esto y creen
que continúa evolucionando o lo hace?  solo
manténgase en un nivel teórico
[Música]
um,
así que en realidad diría que para mí personalmente,
el gran descubrimiento inesperado fue
lo poco que sabemos
sobre la neuroanatomía y la neurofisiología interceptiva
y me refiero a la periferia para
que conozcan nuestro laboratorio con Lisa y Karen
Lisa  maneja las cosas por encima del cuello
, por lo que sabemos que Barrett y
Simmons 2015 hay una serie de otros
buenos artículos que dicen esencialmente que
miras la arquitectura del cerebro y se parece
a la  al menos en la corteza
, sabes que las cortezas motoras interceptiva y visceral
son bastante centrales para la
arquitectura y luego preguntas
qué tipo de señales están llegando desde
la periferia
para luego ser sujetas al procesamiento predictivo
en la corteza
y básicamente te dicen bien en
terreceptivo  señales obviamente,
así que hubo un momento en el que estaba
trabajando con Karen y me di cuenta de que está bien,
así
que parece que en realidad existe esta
estrecha analogía que podríamos plantear como hipótesis
entre
la función conocida de un circuito somatomotor
para el control motor voluntario
y esta forma de manejar la función del reflejo de barril
.
y parece que para el reflejo de barril
, sabe que puede cambiar voluntariamente la
ganancia o la tolerancia, que son
inversas entre sí,
cambiar el punto de operación, sabe que
voluntariamente no parece suceder,
pero parece cambiar
y comienza a verse.  como si ah
, solo podemos dejar de decir
que sabes que hay señales interceptivas
que no sabemos nada  sobre ellos correctamente
y en su lugar preguntar cómo podríamos descomponer
el sistema nervioso autónomo y la
periferia interceptiva en
estos circuitos de control donde hay
una referencia que fluye desde arriba
o posiblemente está incorporada como un previo y
luego un sensor y luego una neurona motora  o
un efector
que, de nuevo,
especulando en total, uno podría imaginar que Loop
podría ser ultra local
o incluso obtener uniones eléctricas
celulares tan locales como podría ser para
cerrar el control del motor Loop y
luego habría potencialmente una escala más meso
puramente dentro de la periferia,
um tal vez  algún tipo de coordinación motora
o acciones de tipo vasoconstricción que
se ejecutan a través de redes neuronales locales
y otros sistemas y luego, cuando
tienes que hacer la llamada al sistema nervioso central
y participar en ese
nivel, es la capacidad más alta de
computación de memoria intermodal como todos estos
otros  fenómenos complejos que luego se
puede ver que tienen el lugar que les corresponde,
tal vez incluso en un cerebro específico  región,
pero todo el rendimiento de dodgeball integrado
no se ubicará en una
región del cerebro más de lo que se ubicaría
en la punta de un dedo
porque todo debe coordinarse
y no todas las llamadas pueden ser locales
y no todas las llamadas pueden ser globales, por lo que
encontrar  descubrir cómo los cuerpos como territorios
y nuestros modelos como mapas
conectan las
cosas va a hacer modelos que sean más
interpretables
mejor alineados con datos empíricos
haciendo predicciones y explicaciones más útiles
es un ángulo muy interesante
y diría que solo para aprovechar un
poco, ya sabes como un  Paradigma de modelado
Creo que esta es una de las verdaderas fortalezas
de la inferencia activa,
es que una vez que estás tratando con estas
densidades de probabilidad y logaritmo de
las densidades de probabilidad,
puedes
comenzar a esbozar estas
estructuras jerárquicas
y eso no significa que cada
inferencia activa jerárquica  el modelo es
automáticamente un mapa del sistema nervioso
pero significa que tienes un
lenguaje que es al menos mínimo  Totalmente
capaz de expresar lo que encontramos tan
abundantemente en la evidencia empírica.
Sí, una parte del
documento que fue muy interesante. Al
leerlo, notamos que,
aunque la mayoría de los documentos están escritos con
palabras, este fue muy directo.
Cada sección tenía un
resumen del contenido del preámbulo.
técnica de emparedado como lo hizo el documento
a una escala más alta, la nomenclatura
fue directa y clara y luego se aclaró la
relación entre las
distribuciones acumulativas y las densidades de probabilidad de tipo PDF clásicas,
pero esto
conecta exactamente
algo que tiene un um
en el caso genérico
un garantizado  puntos de inflexión
valores umbrales interpretables es
por eso que las funciones sigmoideas se usan como
funciones de activación en
redes neuronales artificiales
con
una aproximación laplaciana optimizable
como la
forma cuadrática invertida
que se puede usar como una
probabilidad logarítmica y realmente me gusta
especialmente con la figura 9 que
muestra el paso a paso  la relacion
abre la puerta al like hey si tu  He
visto un sigmoide en algún lugar
ahora, puede pensar en eso como un
PDF que oculta una curva de campana de PDF
y luego, donde ha visto una
curva gaussiana o de campana o una
aproximación laplaciana, puede ir en la otra dirección y pensar
en eso en términos de un
acción de respuesta sigmoidal
y, por lo tanto, rara vez están conectados tan
claramente,
aunque aquellos que están familiarizados es
casi el agua en la que nadan y
aquellos que no están familiarizados no verían
la conexión
y el El desafío y la
oportunidad es quedarse en el
medio
y quedarse
en el espacio de conexión
para llamar la atención sobre algunas de estas
relaciones que, de lo contrario,
podría tener un subcampo completo de
fisiología trabajando en la
curva de respuesta sigmoidea y un subcampo completo de
modelos de procesamiento predictivo jerárquico trabajando en el espacio PDF o log
PDF espacio
y es solo  una derivada y un logaritmo o
una exponenciación y una derivación lejos
de esos dos campos que están formalmente
conectados no solo como una especulación  En el
artículo de revisión, alguien podría o debería hacer
esto, pero como se hizo, simplemente no
conocíamos las
herramientas, así que creo que con respecto a la escritura,
realmente tengo que darle crédito a Lisa y
Karen por muchas cosas en las
que sabes hablar más hablando de
dialéctica.  procesos, ya sabe, tenemos una
dialéctica de escritura muy simple en estos
documentos, que es el autor junior sabe matemáticas,
los autores senior
no se especializaron en matemáticas en su
licenciatura o maestría o clave o
incluso doctorado, sin importar cuán buenos sean
ahora
y el resultado termina siendo  sabes
que siempre te dicen que vuelvas atrás y
expliques cada paso y, por supuesto,
Jordan, que estaba aquí antes, estaba
ayudando mucho con la redacción, la
estructuración y la señalización,
y luego
creo que es la información real que
tu  puede tomar uno de estos sigmoides y
convertirlo en un PDF.
Creo que vino después de
machacarnos la cabeza con parte de la
literatura de procesamiento predictivo incorporado un montón de veces
extraña, es una de esas cosas t
Lo que me atrajo del periódico en
primer lugar fue que el caso de Alice
descendió y la intercepción lo
que me hizo volver a eso fue
um
y hablamos de esto en el  el punto cero
era el
buscador de caminos que gobierna, uh
, los intercambios de perspectiva perfectos frente a la
carpeta de distancia cuando comencé a leer este
artículo. Vi la metamorfosis al
identificar una forma de encontrar cosas y ahora,
después de tener esta conversación contigo
hoy y Jordan y, por supuesto, los
habituales lo sospechan.  es más claro
para mí que este documento está tratando de desempeñar
ese papel de ser
identificador de la perspectiva del buscador de
caminos en lugar de encontrar el camino o esta es nuestra forma
de resolver todos los males del mundo que,
por supuesto, no lo creo  alguna vez fue tu
intención, pero cuando tiras de cosas que
aparentemente están bastante separadas, como la
alostasis y la intercepción,
me emociono, pero no, como dijiste
, bombea el vapor del freno, no
lo entiendas.  demasiado emocionado aquí quiero decir que estamos haciendo
lo mejor que podemos así que en ese nivel
mi amígdala todavía funciona
correctamente
en nuestros pensamientos finales con un
ejemplo de conducción
estamos acumulando velocidad o minimizando
la cantidad de tiempo o nuestros límites de velocidad
incluso establecidos como exteriorizados
normas correctas y marcas estigmérgicas en el
nicho, de
modo que una variedad de automóviles, desde un
automóvil deportivo hasta un camión de 18 ruedas, pueden estar dentro de
una zona de control óptimo teniendo
en cuenta la presencia de cruces peatonales,
etc.
quiero explorar en el punto
dos además de sumergirme en formalismos
tratando de hacer algo de
excavación e intercepción
sobre cómo y dónde
se usa implícitamente la optimización económica como maximización
y dónde se plantean algunas de estas otras nociones
sin necesidad de ser polémicas o
reemplazar la maximización del valor
pero donde podemos ver
estos otros
Criterios de supervivencia
como descomposiciones potencialmente diferentes
de funciones objetivas unificadas que un  re
informativo, etc.
Creo que va a ser
bastante amplio
porque hay más situaciones en las que me
aventuraría en las que preferiríamos tener
capacidad de control y límite de expectativas
y reunión en
lugar de apilamiento de puntos,
así que los comentarios finales te gustan,
sí, así que realmente quiero cerrar.  al
volver a enfatizar que
no sabemos que no lo somos
Creo que tengo esta broma en mi
perfil de Twitter abolir la función de valor y
eso es solo un juego de palabras para las personas
que pueden entenderlo, pero sabes que no lo estamos
intentando  para decirle a la gente lo contrario a su
experiencia subjetiva, oh, realmente no
tienes
un valor que conoces en tu cerebro, en
realidad solo sabes que intenta rastrear
tu trayectoria de referencia,
por lo que en el 0.2 podemos hablar sobre
qué tipos específicos de retroalimentación controlan
qué tipos.
En este documento se habla realmente de los mecanismos de retroalimentación
y creo que,
como saben, es negativo, tanto
negativo en el sentido de evitar el
refuerzo negativo como en el sentido de
Si trato de aplanar una
función de respuesta y ser capaz de responder proporcionalmente
para que sepa, con el beneficio de la
retrospectiva,
este documento tendrá un
dominio de aplicación bastante limitado,
pero es útil porque nos brinda un
lenguaje al que recurrir.  el ex a los
empiristas y decir que esto es lo
que realmente queremos buscar para
cualquier comentario de cierre, de lo contrario, esa es una
gran nota,
Eli y Jordan también, gracias por
venir y participar en dot
Winery y nos vemos la próxima semana,
gracias chicos  te veo la proxima semana